this morning we're learning new
information about how a briefing by
president trump on the pandemic
was suddenly interrupted by the secret
service an agent led the president out
of the room for a few minutes after a
shooting near the white house
a secret service official said last
night that a uniformed officer shot a
man who confronted him
saying he had a gun ben tracy was in the
white house briefing room
as this happened he joins us now ben
what'd you see
well you know as the president was
talking we could tell something was
going on we could see these secret
service agents running
through the windows of the briefing room
there and then the agent that's actually
in the room guarding the president
he was talking to the microphone in his
sleeve he then walked up to the podium
and told the president it was time to go
looks like they're just about going to
be topping records hopefully soon
just minutes into his coronavirus
briefing president trump looked
surprised as a secret service agent told
him he had to quickly leave the room
outside the white house just one block
away a man was shot by the secret
service
there was a shooting outside of the
white house
and seems to be very well under control
overnight the agency said that the
suspect who was a 51-year-old male
ran aggressively towards a secret
service officer outside the white house
the man had allegedly told the officer
he had a weapon
the suspect withdrew an object from his
clothing
he then crouched into a shooter's stance
as this
as if he was about to fire a weapon
that's when the officer fired at the
suspect
hitting him in the torso a source tells
cbs news that the object the subject
held and allegedly pointed
was not a gun back inside president
trump returned to the podium minutes
later
seemingly unfazed do i see him rattled
he also had a positive outlook on the
country's battle against coronavirus
at the end of a fairly short period of
time you're going to be in very very
good shape
all over our country but not only does
the united states now have more than
5 million cases far more than any other
country
there is also new data showing from july
9 to august 6th
more than 170 000 new cases of
coronavirus
have been reported in children a 90
percent increase
over four weeks still president trump
says he has no second thoughts about
pushing schools to reopen
repeating his unfounded claim that
children are not really at risk
for the most part they do very well
the trump administration is now
reportedly considering a new rule that
could block american citizens and
permanent residents from returning to
the country
if they are suspected of having
coronavirus now right now this is just a
draft regulation
but if this comes to be it would be the
latest immigration effort by the
president
during the pandemic it will also likely
be challenged
in court michelle all right ben thank
you